encourage women David
and Kerry Wood
well that's the thing with you pause not
neither one has your same skill set not
everyone has your ear connections and
they're gonna they're gonna have to take
the hard road they're gonna take this
road of coming up with all this money
right so you need at least 25 thousand
dollars but next if you're not screwing
up like these things i'll give you a
knuckle draggers I'm not you know shot
you can't watch everything um one of our
set dressers put a poster of Audrey
Hepburn and no one really caught it to
be honest into we're watching the you
know the cut to the film like it is that
Audrey Hepburn poster in the background
and like yeah so it's like now you got
to get clearance for that and you know
they want three thousand dollars to
clear that poster mmm so you know now
you have a choice of paying three
thousand dollars of clay that poster or
going in and removing it digitally
exactly and that's frame by frame
tracking all that shot to remove it or
replace it so you know stuff like that
gets the time consuming because now you
want to deliver your film and you don't
want to you know do it you can't deliver
it without all this stuff that meets the
right qualifications